emotions are shared in or they're
expressed in a variety of ways and I've
seen people who have really awful things
right like gnarliest of gnarly friends
loved ones whatever um and they don't
cry or they are go into kind of a dark
hole for four or five days and they're
kind of back out back at it and I've had
I've sat with people and they're like
dude everyone's telling me like I'm
going to feel like this or this is going
to happen or and it just doesn't I just
am kind of on to the next and so I think
that that is equally a valid expression
of your what your body is working
through as any other you know I need to
be out for five months um David Kessler
says grief is like a fingerprint it's
Unique to everybody right and so once
like your body's AOE of expression it's
it's Unique to you